put your hands together Mr petees
everybody uh iral bowel syndrome can I
just say that's funny because uh it
sounds like your your bowels are are are
grumpy you're like hey bows leave me
alone take a
nap bowels need to take a
nap that's the moment I'm looking for
right it's a Pure Life moment if
something is terrible on television you
just change the channel here we have to
we have to work it out together
this is life this is real life I'm
really here it's not Obi-Wan Kenobi
really here feel the tension feel life
feel alive this is all you have it's all
you have this is all you
have I'm sorry I'll talk about IBS and
dwars elves making shrimps
shrimps
cockroaches uh good good times that's
that's one of the like most awkward
sounds like let's tell a terrible joke
and uh two peanuts were walking but
don't laugh two peanuts were walking
down the street one was assaulted
right isn't that just the sound
of inside when was
assaulted that's oh that's
living why you I don't know why not you
I'm in a weird place
I I am in a weird place I started doing
South Beach cuz uh yeah why not anyone
doing it good good answer don't do it
don't do it life is short eat pizza pies
and I knew I couldn't keep doing like
you have to do no carbs and stuff and
like no no fun whatso it was awful and I
I had a dream I did it one day one day
one day one day and I had a dream that I
was eating
muffins I had a dream Freud says those
are secret desires my secret desire is
to eat a muffin
my subconscious was like oh to eat a
muffin I can eat a muffin I need to get
that one out of the way so I can dream
about flying and saving the world again
I'm dreaming of muffins that's when they
said this isn't for me ate a muffin and
it was it wasn't actually I didn't have
any muffins I ate
Cheerios and it was almost worth having
done a day and a half of horrible just
like I was sweating like detox of like
all goodness Edibles and then I just ate
the cheer I was like like the doctor
cares I'm like go yourself like I'm
eating it it was so delicious going down
I was like yeah there's whole milk on it
you shouldn't have fat
either don't do the South Beach I want
to dream I'm a wizard not poppy seed oh
life
filled going to be like Archimedes who's
is that the
owl this is my nerd counil here what is
it it's the
what sort of the
right it's a mathematician in like the
adult
version I'm watching cartoons I I can't
I am not an intellectual person look at
me it's just I'm a gentle
man you want to prance on the beach with
me some of you
do it's not sexual it's just sand
between our
toes uh I'm not intellectual at one time
I was talking to my wife and there were
a bunch of mosquitoes by her ears and I
I I tried to look I tried to look smart
that's the mistake I tried to look smart
and I said you know I read a book that
there's an African proverb that says
mosquitoes buzz by your ears because
they're trying to whisper to
you right I thought that was smart in
our comed's mathematician that's what I
was thinking there's a pause she looks
at me and goes Pete did you see that on
Reading
Rainbow turns out she had seen that
episode can I just tell you that is's a
new kind of
humility when you realize your source of
impressive intellectual material doesn't
come from something you read but
something Lavar Burton read for
you but I'm going around like I know
something like yeah if you like books
about
mosquitoes it's floating over my
shoulder want to learn more about him
might be the book for you but don't take
my word for it butterfly in the sky this
guy just embraced his life and said I'm
going to enjoy that
joke it was worth it how much is it to
get in five five worth
itly in the
SK I can go tce as
high take a look it's in a book a
Reading
Rainbow